Speaker 1: Very interesting news on the cannabis
front.
The House of Representatives yesterday passed
a law which would allow banks to provide services
to cannabis companies in states where it is
legal, which is a significant step towards
removing what is a real barrier to the development
of this industry nationally.
As we've talked about before, there has been
a major issue within the cannabis space where
even if it is legal and illegal, that could
be recreational, illegal, recreationally decriminalized,
but medically legal.
And so that's what the pot shops essentially
are selling.
Whatever the case, if you have to deal in
cash because banks aren't allowed to work
with you, that is a major problem.
It's a security problem because people know
you have so much cash around.
It's a problem in a lot of different ways.
Lawmakers voted 321 to 101, which means Democrats,
but also some Republicans to approve the bill
and send it to the Senate.
It is unclear what is going to happen in the
Senate, but we know that banks have been generally
not willing to do business with companies
that are in this business because they could
be running afoul of federal laws.
Now, I'm aware because I have friends in the
industry in, let's say in in Arizona, in Massachusetts
and some other states, they've told me that
there are credit unions that operate only
within one state that seem more willing to
work with cannabis dispensaries and other
businesses, and they feel relatively comfortable
that the government is not going to go after
them.
I don't know whether that's actually true
or not.
I don't know if that's a false sense of security.
But this is a really important thing.
Now, where you get to a conflict is the banking
industry wants this.
And why do they want it?
Well, because it will be hugely profitable.
And there is a contingent of people who are
sort of stuck between what is seemingly a
rock and a hard place for them where they
want cannabis legalization, but they really
are skeptical of the banking industry.
So if the banking industry wants something,
their reflexive reaction is to be against
it.
Listen, banks are going to make money with
this.
Banks are going to make money with anything
that is, you know, whether it's IPOs of companies
that shouldn't be going or holding money for
arms deals, banks are going to make money
regardless.
The question is, do we want to further legitimize
this as an industry so that we can get away
from spending tax money, imprisoning people
who either use, have or sell marijuana and
rather collect tax money from this as a regulated
industry and be able to use that tax money
for public health initiatives, for education,
for whatever the case may be.
I'm of the mindset of I don't want my tax
money going to imprison people involved in
cannabis.
I want to see my tax money bolstered for lack
of a better term by tax money from a legal
and regulated cannabis industry.
My position is clear.
The positions of the United States as a country
are moving more and more in that direction.
This is a big deal.
I don't yet know whether we can expect it
to pass the Senate.
We will see